now the r t Union is leaving leading a
wave of strikes across the railway
Network the biggest for decades but
General Secretary Mick Lynch met with
the new transport secretary and Marie
trevelyn recently and said it was a good
start and a pleasant meeting so is a
fall in the air could a deal be on the
cast let's try and find out
um is the deal on the cards or a strong
action inevitable well there's no deal
on the table on the strike action we've
got down over the next two weeks we'll
go ahead as far as We Know uh what we
need to see from the new secretary of
state is the ability to unblock the
problems in the in the dispute her
predecessor seems to be putting
obstacles in the way of everyone
including the employers by shackling
them to a mandate that was impossible to
deliver they were putting down issues
that we could never accept and the other
trade unions can never accept so I've
asked the new secretary of state and it
was it was a good meeting and a positive
attitude a bit of good will to try and
unthaw this situation we need to get the
thing out of deep freeze and get it on
the table so we can work through the
problem so I've asked her to be a
facilitator for that and I hope she can
do it but I'll have to see whether
there's any proof in that put in over
the next few weeks but you are a bit
optimistic then it does seem like you've
got quite different views so far of the
team you had to be invited to a meeting
than be uh harangued all over the media
which is what we were getting I was
going into certain Studios saying look
let's try and get a deal if you want to
talk to us you can and he was just
slagging us off threatening us with more
and more anti-trade Union laws calling
me a dinosaur and a baron and all this
kind of nonsense and if somebody wants
to meet you and shake your hand that's a
positive start it's the better way to
conduct business than than just slagging
each other off and that's not what I'm
into and I hope that she's not either at
the same time we have seen tightening of
strike laws haven't we on Friday uh what
do you make of that well they're not
just strike laws they're they're an
attack on civil liberties and human
rights so they're trying to make it
impossible for trade unions to exist in
this country and they're trying to make
it impossible in fact to for the people
of this country to campaign against
poverty which is what many of them are
changing if there is no trade Union
freedom and it's impossible to conduct
lawful industrial action people will
have to go another way they'll have to
think of other means of doing it they're
trying to regulate unions and they've
said they're going to cut red tape the
only people that are going to be subject
to stringent regulation are the trade
unions and they want to regulate the
relationship between the union and its
members that's not acceptable people
will always regret further oppression of
Trade union rights because we won't be
able to protest we've got a new police
bill that's going to stop us protesting
on the streets and we're going to have a
set of Trade union laws that attempt to
stop us having a balanced equation in
the workplace and that's not acceptable
you say that if it in your words becomes
impossible to strike people will find
other means what what do you mean what
if people can't take lawful industrial
action they're less to take unlawful
industrial action and we're fast get
into a situation where we're going to
have the laws that are as oppressive as
those that exist in Russia and China and
back in Poland before son of danush came
along and took unlawful industrial
action in that environment to break free
of the oppression of the old Soviet Bloc
and the Communist Regime over there what
specifically just just to come in
because obviously it's quite a big
statement to say that the laws are as
oppressive as those in Russia and around
the world
they're going to make it impossible for
us to have lawful ballots they're going
to make it impossible through let's just
explain what well because they're going
to raise the thresholds to a level where
it will be very difficult 50 turnouts
and 50 of the of the whole population in
the ballot uh to get to get a yes vote
if if we brought those in into local
councils for instance or indeed in
Parliament most of the people that
currently serve on local councils
wouldn't be councilors if we brought
those into Parliament most of the people
in Parliament do not receive 50 of the
vote in parliamentary elections they
won't allow us to do electronic voting
it all has to be done by the Royal Mail
uh by postal voting they won't allow us
to use any modern techniques they want
to fine us for any mistakes we make
during ballots that we could finish
trade unions and they want us to give
four weeks notice which will make
effective industrial action very
difficult to carry out and they want us
to do this continual round of referenda
uh based on every single offer or every
discussion that we have of an employer
which allows us running around like
spinning tops if your employer offers me
1.95 one week and the next week offers
me 1.96 uh cars equating saying that'll
have to do a referendum every time that
somebody scratches their nose it's a
ridiculous situation and it's going to
make it impossible for us to operate we
spoke to the unison General Secretary a
bit earlier on the program and she was
saying that look you know the a
technical General Striker is unlikely to
happen but yes there is coordinated
action
for many people that is basically a
general strike
well you usually need to make their
power effective and we don't at the end
of the day is negotiations fail we've
got intransigent employers and many
Employers in this country are making
super profits the rich are getting
richer than they've ever been so unions
are organizing together that would be
fair well we talk to each other will you
be silly for unions not to coordinate
their forces and so we're taking action
alongside the postal workers next week
alongside the house left Union and if
other people want to join in a wave of
response and resistance to what's going
on where the rich are being made richer
all of the time we've seen that in the
budget on Friday where the people
everybody who's under 155 000 in salary
will be poorer and every Everybody above
that salary will be richer well we've
got to be able to rebalance our society
and our economy so it does sound like
we'll be seeing coordinated action
strike action this if we cannot get
settlements we'll have to coordinate our
actions and what do you make of Labor's
response
well I want to see labor win I want
labor to win the next election I want
kirst armor to be our next prime
minister that's what I want but I think
in order to do that he's got to show
that he empathizes and sympathize of
what working people are going through
they're really struggling people are
scared that they're going to lose their
homes never mind to eat them people are
going to face landlords that are pushing
up pushing up rents and banks that are
pushing up mortgage rates that's on top
of the utility bills crisis and the
price of of living he's got to show that
he identifies with what we're going
through has he shown that yet I haven't
seen it uh if I could see it I'd be
delighted so I'm hoping this week that
we can all come away saying look Kia
storm was on our side we can put our
shoulder to his wheel to get him elected
and he's putting his shoulder to work in
people's will to help them in their
everyday problems but I want to see a
set of values I don't mind about
detailed policy that's to come but I
want him to show that he's got the
values that identify with the men and
women in this country that are really
struggling are frightened of what's in
front of them so do you think he should
be on a picket line then I'm not worried
about whether he's on a picket line or
not I don't expect him to be there but I
want him to identify with our causes and
the issues that we Face how does he do
that then I think he sets out a program
some some uh Charters some some values
that say we've got a housing crisis in
this country we've got an energy price
uh problem in this country we've got a
wages problem and he needs to say that
I'm I'm on your side and when we get
into Power we're going to bring in a set
of measures regulations and laws that
rebalance the way that working people
are treated in this country and gives
them a voice in the workplace and in
society do you ever speak to him I spoke
to him over the piano crisis and he was
really good he was really on our side I
don't expect him to do what I tell him
to do I don't think well the world works
like that I come up to the labor
conference to try and influence to talk
to friends talk to people that don't
like me and there are plenty of them as
well so you know we're here to influence
and try to help in some ways I'm hoping
that he can show that he's sympathetic
to what we're going through Railway
workers are really struggling and
millions of other workers are really
struggling we've got the personal
workers we've got the dockers on strike
right now in Liverpool he can show that
he's on their side and sympathizes with
what they do that doesn't mean he has to
Wade directly into each and every
dispute but he's got a show he's on the
side of the workers because after all
this is a labor party the names on the
tin and he's got to show that he's a
friend of every worker in this country
okay thank you very much on the program
to say Nick Lynch out there of the r d